[Music]
in flight hacks news submitted by rosy
cheeks here are 14 ways to get better
sleep on an airplane first-class coach
or economy or whatever fly private jets
a good drink yeah and while you get your
dick sucked journey I don't have were
you playing with feeling
not even real life oh my god that's a
good airline name dream yeah Debbie time
I would book with them real quick nice
so here's a list of some travel bloggers
who recommended I need these I can never
sleep well I'm gonna listen to them if
they're shorter than 511 if they're 511
and under yeah I'm with you girl no I'm
sick of it they have that privilege and
they don't [ __ ] welcome that's true
so the first one says avoid sugar and
alcohol and then this is from Meg Jared
a travel blogger that's just sleeping in
general yeah avoid alcohol listen she
says I know someone called the fun
police but you should skip that free
airline lounge champagne and avoid
alcohol and sugar completely while you
might think alcohol will send you to
sleep this is usually only short lasting
maybe three to four hours and you'll
then wake up with the headache feeling
thirsty and won't be able to get back to
sleep fine if your flight is only 3 to 4
hours but if you're on a long-haul
flight this might be counterproductive
with sugar when you're sitting down for
long periods of time you're not using up
a lot of energy so when you eat salty or
sugary foods this ends up causing a lot
of bloating and nobody wants to feel
bloated while they're flying what [ __ ]
wrote this [ __ ] oh girl do drinks on my
wake up with a headache and for are you
kidding me it only does be hydrate you
which causes headaches if only two
drinks would get me to sleep
Jesus next one take melatonin when going
on long-haul flights I always bring a
sleeping aid such as melatonin that
helps me sleep better on those long
overnight flights just to JoVE and up
said you know what you know what helps
me sleep is the business class like
Singapore Airlines when you lay down all
that
nice yeah okay melatonin has been proven
don't quote me on this I'm just on Jake
this commune is to create spaces in your
brain really yeah are you sure it's not
it make you can make you a little slower
over time if you use it regularly so
[ __ ] melatonin I ain't a commissioner
I thought we naturally produce melatonin
we do but you don't [ __ ] need to take
the product as well in addition to but I
think it's because you're lacking the
normal amount that you need to put it in
if you're a [ __ ] science professor
dude how are you supposed to know you're
liking the no amount like most people
just take it because they can't sleep
right it's not because melatonin is not
being produced in their body they're
taking it like almost because they're
like well I need this too because there
are diggit to their phones and then they
have too much caffeine in their system
so they're taking melatonin anything
that [ __ ] with you like that memory
anything like that energy drink okay
look for this study that correlates
taking energy drinks to [ __ ] brain
cell loss and I'm out and I'm out you
know what's crazy a lot of [ __ ]
people keep sending me these [ __ ]
articles about energy drink and the
damage that they do and I'm like I'm not
[ __ ] Nicki don't send it to me I'm
not Steve don't send it to me yeah you
know what I've looked at a lot of those
I've looked at a lot of those and you
know what they're not doctors and not
they're not as delicious so you never
physically have felt the energy drinks I
use to drink a lot and it was just like
[ __ ] with my stomach
[ __ ] we didn't work out I just met a
healthy 55 year old man that had a
stroke from energy drinks oh they did
they said like this is from energy he's
like stay away from it I don't do it
anymore
how many died on a good day oh [ __ ] I
need a drink too two big monsters how do
you about two and like I kind of got an
ulcer
okay that was soo kidney stones oh that
says I had one kidney stone
I mean kidney stones twice yeah well
when I had him ten years ago I never
even touched him you think then how big
was it did you have to pass it now I had
to get surgery removed
he's like I didn't have energy jury I
had diet coke I actually didn't diet ten
years ago I didn't have any of that [ __ ]
we don't believe you until Nicky's here
going [ __ ] you only ten years ago no one
could call you on your boss's mistake
exactly so yeah by the way my mother the
lying [ __ ] don't trust her
mothers are lying [ __ ] actually mine
yeah cuz she disputes me that's true
she'll own it I'm not alright necrolyte
Isaac to make them go to bed I'm not a
[ __ ] how's that making out a [ __ ] next
one says wear loose shoes one thing I do
really helps on long nights five or more
hours is where slightly loose slip-on
shoes if I'm planning to sleep on the
flight I might end up with swollen feet
but if there's some room in the shoe
I'll be comfortable anyway plus a little
room allows for socks on chilly flights
who the [ __ ] is wearing stilettos a real
hack where like if you press the button
hard enough they'll actually recline all
the way what happens when websites pay
like independent contractors 50 bucks to
write [ __ ] [ __ ] or travel hack like
who go who's is like I'm gonna take a
flight let me buy some shoes or one size
bigger yeah like that makes no sense my
shoes these are 14 ways to get better
sleep on an airplane why is it always
arbitrarily 14 15 it's because they paid
somebody 50 bucks to [ __ ] expand the
list out you know sometimes there's only
the only needs to be three tips three
good ones right what's the next one I
want it if there's gold I'm okay with I
just tell them all to you maybe you'll
find some gravel along another one it
was choose a seat wisely try to get a
window seat so you can lean against the
wall [ __ ] you I always want I'll now I
used to love window but I hate tapping
people and asking them to move
I hate I'll cuz they always run into me
on purpose the cart ladies you're just
why dude buffets are sticking out man as
soon as they get to your aisle they
angle it a little bit back ah [ __ ] this
guy who's buffing okay and then the next
one says tire yourself out once I hit my
departure gate and the stress level of
travel stabilizes I began my pre-flight
I mean my flight pre check to ensure
smooth travel I start drinking as much
water as possible to keep hydrated
use whatever time to piss 20 times on
the plane or take off to move around the
airport airports are great places to
walk and get your endorphins immune and
circulatory systems pumping I do that
too walking I use airport seating
seating for leg lifts and lower body
muscle toning and use walls for push-ups
and arms that's what works out at
airport this chick is a robot dude seen
girls do
all right seen people do like yoga and
stuff cuz they know they're gonna be
sitting French stretching this will show
you legless [ __ ] just one time I just
Asian lady behind me blast in [ __ ]
music the whole time on a plane and I
was like what the [ __ ] is her problem
she's playing like this gentle string
instrument through a boombox so angry
was she getting a massage loudest [ __ ]
it was gentle I was like no but it was
like loud right so it's like ding dong
ding ding or whatever that's race that's
really it was real it wasn't it wasn't
she wasn't saying all that I mean
although it sounded very similar that's
racist you know the difference okay
school no but she was playing this music
fuel boombox and just sitting there and
everyone thought I was just like no one
told her she mean nobody said that's why
my mom I would have said some [ __ ] why
don't you say anything if she's
disrupting your peace she was three
hours back
flight attendant my mom has this [ __ ]
answering machine on the necklace that
plays this Buddhist chant over and over
and over I said yep that one yeah come
on that what is with this why aren't you
doing cuz it's just a Buddhist chant
she's just one step to bless she wants
the home I don't know she's nuts it's
magical spells next one invest in a good
travel pillow I could agree to this some
people like memory foam some people like
the ones you blow up guys and style that
works for you before you board the plane
with that pillow test it out on your own
couch and you'll be able to sleep
infinitely on your next place cuz if you
buy it at the airport it's like $600
yeah they never work for me me neither
I've tried so many different pillows I
even got that
one that you wrap around your neck
because my my thing with like the
regular neck pillows is that my neck
always leans forward so I did that one
and it still lean forward whoa just
attached to my [ __ ] you gotta get used
to doing this this sounds like I'm stuck
in the conversation with my grandma and
she's like well yeah I just bought this
pillow and I'm gonna test it out before
my flight no no don't yes and boring
conversation hey that might work better
works way better
I literally try to put neck pillow at
similars I have a neck at the same
problem we're like no matter how I
positioned by the time I sleep it's like
this line doesn't do that well you guys
don't sleep like this I start that way
but I never end that way the whole time
[ __ ] yeah though hurt I'll sleep on the
table I'll bring the table down are you
he's pretty talks I'm like almost six
feet yeah you can do that it's it's kind
of like Africa yeah I'm I'm five-eleven
I'm [ __ ] squished something yeah no
it's not 100% comfortable I bored I
could barely do I'm six more y'all
privileges [ __ ] you're six four yeah
you're all privileges [ __ ] airplanes
dude I know I just didn't think you
would you think you was excessive you
know I'm six four and a half
[ __ ] and you're a shrimp to me
shrimp meditate even if you're stuck in
the middle seat or just dread being on
an airplane to begin with let alone
getting some good sleep on it fear not
the number one thing you can do is focus
on your mindset stay aware of the
thought narrative happening in your head
don't psych yourself out and get
stressed before you even head to the
airport take a quiet moment to set an
intention to enjoy the entire journey
starting with the airport experience the
practice gratitude that you're lucky
enough to go on a trip that's cool smack
her while she said this is [ __ ] 14
travel hacks for Buddhists or something
like less time for this like traveling
could be kind of overwhelming sometimes
you know
you guys travel a lot so this is for
people that like they don't know what to
expect you know we proofread this [ __ ]
go that was the most boring sentence I
ever read in my life Stephen green from
no I wouldn't write in anything like
that you correct the state you correct I
would have just said one thing one thing
is make more money yeah that's a better
travel yes
you fly first-class and shut the [ __ ] up
yeah yeah cuz I can't yet yeah but I
will one day you will win it that's why
I'm gonna [ __ ] sit in economy with my
Achy Breaky back and I'm gonna be like
I'm practicing gratitude right now cuz
I'm going somewhere where I want to be
the best thing knows when you're in
business class you could look at
everyone like this come as that yeah I
got if you never world scum yeah I'll
give you the actual travel hack if you
could pick a seat somehow where there's
no one around you and hopefully no one
sits then you get to sprawl just a
little bit [ __ ] is that a hack that's
just obvious only once a year like
you're saying that no one's gonna sit
next to them you just got a wish and
that's why this is a realistic works
like a lottery winner right now he's
like I got a hack for you buy a
Powerball ticket again it works every
time like thanks Bart I'm giving it my
my seeding heck so it was when it's just
me and KCC flying anywhere I try to get
one of those three rows but then I book
the window and the aisle so then
hopefully no one like sitting in the
middle of two people so then we end up
getting that middle seat does it happen
a lot sometimes if the free if the
flight isn't popular like you're in
there and then like this way everybody
knows it's about to get full in here and
then you're like at that point it's fine
because then one of us will just switch
if they're lucky enough to left or
they're gonna come there's no way I want
15h and that's mine yep I've seen
somebody like that no that's all I'm a
ticket I want that seat I'm a middle
seat person those other people that
probably believed like oh the reason why
you have to sit in your seat is because
in case the plane crashes at least they
know which bones will lock - exactamundo
whoa I never thought I I stopped like
really bad sciatica like really bad back
problems so none of this health is like
the only thing I would do would just
walk around the plane just walk around
the button way harder and it goes back a
little bit more it wouldn't work
I've seen those first clad pas first
class pods you'll like this yeah one day
what we'll all fly in one of those
[Music]